Mình hãy nhìn đối cùng là một like ấy, bởi vì mình không có được lâu.
Nếu mà lọc các bạn chẳng quanh,
nó thể đúc nào cũng có bất trường cả khi mình rộu xung gí sọng
để mình là bảo đi lòng,
mình bạc cái bởi quanh là mình rộu xung trọng
và giữ xọng đó là tất cả những cái độ
và giữ mình tạch thái xung thí yu kiến và hơi thí giữ
như kịp là hơi hơi bạng quanh là tạch thái xung sọng.
Bạc cái bất trường này nó chưa làm là ra có bất trường cái.
Mình cứ nghĩ một cái đứt để mà mình mọng
hơi hơi thái đứt,
cái độ hữ mà thệ mũ,
mà cuê mình hãy đàn vào gọi xong.
Đặt bị kệ,
những cái mù mưa là vẻ không có hả hả?
Vì cả chỉ có một cái uống đường nhắn của mình có rộ,
đệ có bởi xong.
Nó là xong này mình hiểu cuộc đại mình có khổ nhất.
Cái này cũng không khổ mạng.
Cái gia đánh mà mình khi tổng của mình hiểu xong.
Cái hả cả nó trong mình xích kêu đệ?
Cục đại mình xong này có những cái gì đó hổ.
Thì chắc chắn trong mình trăm mình sẽ buổi quen.
Mấy vì không cái gì thì hãy khổ hơi những cái mình là xong.
Đi quên, mũ sẽ theo cái sẹp tồi vô của Cast of First Step, mới nhất.